hi everybody do you know the French for
stuntman I forget the English machine
its cascade oh so house we are all
cascada you and me
which we need to end we should take care
of our security and as developers
security means automatic tests in CSS
and the emoji is for is the face of my
colleagues when I told them I was
talking about CSS and tests and one of
them told me oh yes those things with an
screenshots not only actually we CSS I
associated to to do those things
normal syntax error since tool inter I
test my function with unit test will
start after I muster my update impact it
means when I update my SAS code I can
visually see what change in the
generated CSS I test visually my own
website with with tools like puppeteer
and finally the screenshot to test
visually the changes so let's focus on
those one because we have short time for
those I will use two tools the test
framework to test answers first I
install just just configure it with a to
attribute to say where are my tests and
how to find out the pattern on the file
name and then a script to executive
just give me the ability to expect
something to be something else which
after how I will use it and then when
you test you get those results on the
other end I will use sass the nosiest
notion of sass I require it in my script
and this is the best part such as a
render sync method which I can pass my
source code and it returns the generated
CSS in a string so now I have the
ability to I'll function to go from
Scot to CSS and unexpect putting all
together I can test my function like
this I import the functions a CSS file
in the data of render sync I test my
function on a fake selector and I expect
the result to be the CSS I want to be
returned by the function so now how can
i man master the object unpacked it
means in I change something in the sass
I want to visually detect what change in
the CSS so for that I will use snapshot
testing it means I did my CSS CSS code
it generator CSS the test is always
green because it was first then I really
did the SAS code run the test and as you
can see is the same result so everything
is OK and then I edit the SAS code
another time something changed just tell
me how something is different it does
not mean it's an error but it's
different and I have the ability to
check what's the difference and thanks
to the update attribute options I can
say okay everything is OK you can update
the snapshot and know that snapshot is
the reference to do that and just gives
a method called too much snapshot and
that's it
you put the CSS and the expert and
that's it so now we are able to test our
function to master the impact of our
updates and for if you want to dig in
deep deep inside and see the example for
all the other you can check my repo made
for this or ask me on Twitter thank you
[Music]